but it's a two-point lead
let's calm down and be happy with that
okay let's continue continue in the same
way
see if he's learned his lesson
this obviously speaks volume of
my dearth of ideas in the opening
against
uh against danish
c6 however
that's pretty similar to what i tried to
do against alireza and uh in the last
since lewis wrap it in blitz in the
f3 nimzo so how about
if i what happens if i go a5 now
there's only one way to find out
so the real question is whether he can
play which base six
but once i take on
on uh b6 it does
he does find himself in a bit of an
unpleasant pin
so he's hoping that was going to be a
serious factor
so i'll take it
then i'll go bishop d3
let's see what he has in store
most natural which
is it that simple
it's really that simple
that would be a bummer
yeah probably it's that simple
you can go dc4 now but i'm pretty happy
with that i go bishop c2
i sack the pawner e4 e5 bliss in a blitz
game that looks like
excellent practical compensation but now
i cannot sacrifice the pawn anymore
um because the exchange of
bishops would pretty much extinguish all
my attacking potential
so now i gotta take the game more along
positional lines
yeah i don't want to exchange on d5
unless i can go see
c4 later on so we'll try and keep the
tension
c5 is obviously a decent option now
i think maybe then i'll go bish b2
and then he cannot he cannot win uh
win a pawn by cd4 cd4 dc4 because i got
knight c4
bishop if bishop c4 there's rookie eight
and then i take back and i have
some structural advantage
so i'm sort of hoping for the same has
happened
in the last the last nimso game that we
played that
this bishop on b2 is gonna be a very
strong piece at some point
it's not opposed um
by by an opponent bishop and
it's pretty easy to imagine a scenario
where
um everything gets opened
okay so queen c7 um
that was missed
but i don't know if it's any good i go
knight d6
no
yeah i think just knight fd6 is a pretty
good move
because if bishop d3 i take when he ate
and i think he just loses
say whole exchange and if he takes on d6
um i just
should i change first
i guess probably not
but basically regardless i have two
bishops against
two knights and i should have have a
comfortable positional advantage
i don't think he has any tricks based on
b5
bishop b5 and queen b6 after he's taken
on c
d4 cd4 cd4 because his knight on d7
can be captured and i remain a full
pawn to the good so i think i'm i'm just
considerably better here from a
positional point of view
um yeah we'll just go back
take with take on a1 with the queen
yeah that's why i took with the bishop
on a6 because i didn't want to give him
the file for free and he can go
e5 at any point the problem is that
his problems are not really solved by
that um
whenever he captures now that he
has got a5 i probably will take an a8
though
um because i feel that now the position
is more open
the a file doesn't matter as much
h5 i think it's just weakening i'll go
h3
um to prevent knight g4 from happening
and if h4 happens at any point i feel
after things clear up in the center that
will probably
be more of a weakness than the strength
so i believe i'm just much better here
yeah cd4 cd4 he exchanges everything
which means that there's no
not a ton of material at the board
left on the board but i just have such a
big positional advantage
that i believe it's
it's well it's not decisive but it's uh
not actually that far from
from decisive rook a2
this is missed there is
no doubt about that this was just missed
but i'm not majorly worried my position
is just too solid for him to
to really bother me you cannot move
either knight to e4 because i'll
take an f6 or c5 with mating threats
and uh this also
looks very suspicious bishop c5 followed
by rook d8
also bishop c3 and then rd8 probably
that's even better
i'll give a check i'll go queen b5
yes no checks only move is king f8
now bishop c6 is winning
rookie 8 followed by bishop g7 should be
winning
yeah bishop c6 is just the easiest i
believe
yeah no no need to complicate it
okay he need resigns that was pretty
good
i gotta say uh queen c7
well the whole plan of dc for queen c7
was clearly
flawed in that he missed
night 96 but i think overall
a fairly good game